it's a weird story why does she come
back to this country she had to have
known she'd be
arrested she was living abroad she's got
foreign passports at least one
probably more going on here than we know
so here's a thought experiment for you
oklahoma city is one of the most
conservative
metro areas in the united states donald
trump won almost 60 percent of the vote
there four years ago
imagine if the conservatives who
presumably run local government in
oklahoma city sent an
email to every african-american
municipal employee
telling them to report to a special
meeting imagine that when those
employees arrived again
black employees only nobody else allowed
they were informed that the fact they
were black was deeply
offensive in fact it was a kind of crime
and the only way to atone for the sin
of their blackness was to apologize for
it apologize for being born black and
then work to shed all traces of your
black identity
stop spending so much time around your
black friends stop repeating things your
black parents told you growing up start
admitting out loud that you hate
yourself for having black skin
imagine if that actually happened in
this country what would you think of it
you'd be horrified obviously it's
completely disgusting
it is immoral to attack people for how
they were born it's always immoral and
by the way it's also illegal
the justice department would never
tolerate something like that
civil rights division would shut down
the program tonight and would bring
criminal charges against the people who
ran it and you would applaud them
as they did that and we would too
so with that in mind consider what is
happening right now in one of america's
most
liberal cities seattle four years ago
hillary clinton got
87 percent of the vote in seattle there
aren't many places more loyal to the
democratic party
recently the city of seattle summoned
its white employees and
only its white employees to a meeting
and then informed them their skin color
is a crime the city called this
anti-racism training events like it are
taking place all over the country right
now in schools local governments
corporations the military
the city of seattle named its training
session interrupting
internalized racial superiority and
whiteness
chris ruffo of city journal wants to
know exactly what went on in a meeting
like that so he filed a public records
request
here's what he found white employees in
seattle were informed that their
so-called
white qualities were offensive and
unacceptable
those qualities included perfectionism
objectivity
and individualism the employees were
told to stop
exhibiting these characteristics and
instead they were ordered to undertake
quote the work of undoing your own
whiteness
in order to achieve that in order to
erase the traits they were born with
white employees in seattle were ordered
to give up the following
they were ordered to give up comfort
they were ordered to give up
spending time with their their family
they were ordered
to give up guaranteed physical safety
control over other people and the land
relationships
with some other white people niceties
from neighbors and colleagues
and quote the certainty of your jobs
prepare to be unemployed pale employees
of seattle your skin color disgusts us
all of that actually happened in seattle
check out chris ruffo's new piece in
city journal if you want more details on
it
but again atrocities like this aren't
just happening in seattle they're
happening
everywhere some will almost certainly
happen in your kids school this fall no
one will ask your permission before they
do it
they'll just attack your children for
how they were born the people doing the
attacking by the way
would tell you with a straight face how
opposed they are to gay conversion
therapy because of course
it's immoral to try to change people's
intrinsic qualities
they wouldn't see the irony in that more
likely they don't care about irony
this isn't about principles it's about
hate humiliation and power
it is about hurting people it always is
telling people they're inferior because
the
of their skin color was wrong when it
happened 60 years ago in alabama
it is every bit is wrong when it happens
today in seattle or at yale or google
headquarters or at your kids elementary
school
attacking people on the basis of their
race is a
sin there is nothing worse for a country
they can try to disguise it with
orwellian terms like anti-racism
but this is the purest kind of race hate
it will destroy america faster than
anything else
don't put up with it resist speak out
fight back
this is totally wrong until you stand up
it will continue